pour une journée qui sera chargée
puisque je vous rappelle que nous avons
l'audition de la ministre des Sports
après les
QG mais en attendant cette audition nous
avons ce matin une audition importante
consacrée
aux jeux vidéos secteur pour lequel
notre commission il y a presque 10 ans
en 2013 avec nos collègues André gatelin
et Bruno Retailleau
avait commis un rapport qui avait fait
date dont le titre n'a pas pris une ride
ou devrais-je dire n'a pas pris un pixel
à savoir les jeux vidéo une industrie
culturelle innovante pour nos
territoires
la Commission a estimé qu'il était temps
de revenir sur ce secteur du jeu vidéo
porteur prometteur mais encore mal
identifié par les pouvoirs publics et
c'est vrai que ça revient relativement
peu dans les discussions que nous
pouvons avoir
et si pour ça que je remercie nos
invités de ce jour madame Chalmette
Michel maître président du syndicat des
éditeurs de logiciels de loisirs le sel
Nicolas Vignol délégué général ainsi que
Julien Villedieu délégué général du
Syndicat national des jeux vidéo le SNJV
et je précise que votre Président
Monsieur sarde qui devait nous rejoindre
et cas contact le virus étant encore
assez présent nos intervenants devraient
nous permettre de réaliser un point
précis sur ce secteur et de tracer ses
perspectives d'avenir pour mémoire le
jeu vidéo est selon les sources mais
vous nous le préciserez certainement la
première ou la seconde industrie
culturelle en France avec un chiffre
d'affaires en 2021 de près de 5,6
milliards d'euros soit le double du
cinéma et de la musique enregistrée
c'est dire l'importance du jeu vidéo
dans les pratiques culturelles des
Français qui sont 73% à jouer au moins
occasionnellement avec
je le note au passage 98 % des 10 à 14
ans je ne sais pas parmi les membres de
la commission quel est le pourcentage
nous vérifierons peut-être à l'issue de
cette audition le jeu vidéo s'inscrit
c'est sa nature dans un environnement
technologique en perpétuelle et
évolution avec l'arrivée prochaine de la
réalité virtuelle promise depuis
longtemps ou bien l'évolution de la
monétisation avec l'éruption des loot
Box vous en parlerai certainement qui
promettent moyennant finance un avantage
aller à toi et nous aurons bien sûr à
réfléchir sur les conséquences de de
cellootbox notamment je pense cependant
également au grand mouvement
capitalistique avec le projet de rachat
par Microsoft de l'éditeur américain
Activision Blizzard
autrefois je le signale au passage
propriété de Vivendi rachat par
Microsoft pour lequel l'Autorité de la
concurrence britannique est en train de
d'analyser le dossier ce sera chasse
le montant de sur achat il est évalué
après à plus de 70 milliards de dollars
soit la capitalisation boursière
d'Airbus en 2021 ce qui nous donne une
idée de la puissance de ces secteurs
économiques on pourra aussi parler de la
situation catipidalistique d'Ubisoft qui
a fait l'objet de
d'une série d'articles ces dernières
semaines notre pays dispose d'atouts
reconnu avec des éditeurs réputés dans
le monde entier et des écoles qui
forment parmi les meilleurs spécialistes
le jeu vidéo bénéficie d'un soutien
public via le crédit d'impôt je vidéo
pour près de 70 millions d'euros
régulièrement attaqués par les
commissions des finances mais jamais
évalué de manière précise telles sont
quelques-unes des questions que nous
souhaiterions aborder avec vous je
propose à chacune de vos organisations
prendre la parole pour environ 10
minutes dans un propos liminaire et
ensuite nous vous poserons des questions
ce sera notre rapporteur Julien
barjetton qui qui commencera et après
bien sûr chacun et chacune d'entre vous
pourra intervenir et enfin je rappelle
que cette audition est captée est
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
je vous laisse la parole je ne sais pas
qui commence madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci de nous
recevoir je vais d'abord me présenter
donc moi je suis Julie Chalmet je suis
la présidente du sel mais je suis
également la directrice générale de
Bessèges de France qui a aussi été fait
l'objet d'un rachat par Microsoft pour
la somme modique de 7 milliards de
dollars donc on a été un peu
effectivement
cette somme qui était une somme record a
ensuite été un peu occultée par ce
rachat massif de d'Activision bizarre
donc on est effectivement le témoin de
rapprochement et de concentration au
sein de notre industrie
le Zelda France est un éditeur qui s'est
implanté en France il y a plus de 10 ans
on détient également un studio en France
qui s'appelle arcane qui est un qui a
produit des jeux
très reconnus par la communauté des
joueurs
par ailleurs je suis également à
cofondatrice de woman in game ce qui est
une association qui
œuvre pour que doubler le nombre de
femmes dans notre industrie je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter de
la place des femmes dans cette industrie
voilà et pour vous présenter pour vous
présenter rapidement le seul donc le
seul regroupe les éditeurs de jeux vidéo
on nous avons nous avons tous les grands
éditeurs autour de la table les
constructeurs également les
constructeurs de consoles
Nintendo Sony et Microsoft voilà et donc
comme vous l'avez dit l'industrie est en
croissance fait une croissance
remarquable aujourd'hui l'industrie
représente 5,6 milliards d'euros en
France
on a connu des années de croissance à
deux chiffres
quasiment depuis 6 ans l'année dernière
on a eu un léger tassement mais on est
dans une industrie qui est extrêmement
cyclique qui est portée aussi par le
rythme des de des sorties de consoles
des nouvelles consoles de jeux vidéo
donc on a bon espoir de renouer sur une
croissance à deux chiffres dans les
années qui viennent
au-delà des chiffres qui sont toujours
importants effectivement qui nous
soutient comme la première industrie
culturelle en France je pense que il est
surtout important de rappeler la place
que le jeu vidéo occupe dans le dans le
dans le cœur des Français et dans leur
dans leurs occupations vous l'avez dit
effectivement
tous les presque tous les Français
jouent 73% des Français jouent
occasionnellement 53% je vous
régulièrement
et ce que je trouve remarquable
effectivement vous devez l'avoir
constaté auprès de vos jeunes
générations tous les jeunes jouent et ce
qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'on
observe que le les seniors aussi sont
devenus joueurs on a on a ce chiffre un
peu que j'aime bien rappeler que plus de
50% des plus de 55 ans son joueur donc
c'est un chiffre qui est un peu qui est
un peu toujours un peu étonnant mais
c'est dû à la fois au fait que la
population des joueurs
la vieilli bien évidemment on est dans
une industrie qui désormais le premier
des premiers jeux vidéo sont sortis il y
a 50 ans
mais également on observe que le
catégorie plus seniors sont arrivées
récemment par le jeu vidéo notamment par
la voix du téléphone mobile
et puis aussi une autre un autre fait à
rappeler qui est important c'est que les
femmes sont joueuses elles a
représentent la moitié de la population
des juin si si vous je vois des gens qui
vous êtes vous êtes joueuses très
certainement
et il y a
oui il est donc les joueuses enfin les
joueuses représentent la moitié de la
population des joueurs donc ça aussi
c'est un fait très intéressant et c'est
aussi évidemment ce qui nous ce qui nous
encourage à poursuivre nos efforts pour
féminiser cette industrie et que les
femmes soient plus massivement présentes
dans le dans la production
voilà pour les grands chiffres du sel je
vais passer la parole à Julien peut-être
pour qu'il représente plus la partie
justement des studios et du
développement
merci beaucoup Julie bonjour à toutes et
à tous merci monsieur le Président pour
votre invitation à intervenir ce matin
devant votre commission et merci à vous
toutes et tous d'être présent c'est
c'est important pour nous de vous dire
qui nous sommes et ce que nous
représentons parce que souvent le jeu
vidéo est méconnu voir
mépriser par un certain nombre de prêts
on va dire d'idées reçues qui lui colle
à la peau on va essayer ce matin
peut-être ensemble de vous donner une
image la plus réaliste possible de ce
que nous représentons Julie Chalmette et
Nicolas Vignolles évoqueront sans doute
un peu plus dans le détail l'ensemble
des sujets qui qui tiennent au marché à
la consommation à l'univers des joueuses
et des joueurs quant à moi en tant que
représentant donc du Syndicat National
jeux vidéo qui représente les
entreprises de conception et production
de jeux vidéo en France je vais essayer
de m'efforcer de vous faire découvrir
l'envers du décor du miroir et de faire
comprendre comment ce conçoivent les
jeux vidéo en France et vous expliquer
un petit peu quelle est cette longue
histoire et c'est selon héritage que
nous avons dans cette industrie à la
fois culturelle mais aussi numérique
c'est ce qui fait son double ADN et sans
doute parfois la difficulté que l'on a
appréhender cet objet culturel parfois
non identifié le jeu vidéo en France
d'abord c'est une histoire d'une
cinquantaine d'années avec des
créatrices et des créateurs de renom qui
ont inventé je ne sais pas si vous le
savez mais certains genres de jeux comme
on peut avoir dans le cinéma dans la
littérature des genres qui sont issus de
grands écrivains ou de grands cinéastes
français nous avons eu également la même
chose dans le dans le jeu vidéo ces
genres qui aujourd'hui sont réputés à
travers le monde on a eu également sur
ces 50 ans de très grandes licences de
très grands propriétés intellectuelles
réalisées par des entreprises françaises
et qui rayonnent à travers le monde
c'est probablement une des
particularités que vous devrez retenir
ce matin de ce qui caractérise notre
industrie c'est que le jeu vidéo
français rayonne à travers le monde
aujourd'hui plus de 95% de ce que nous
produisons en France et consommer
distribuer jouer partout sur la planète
il est inenvisageable pour nos
développeurs et nos créatrices et
créateurs de concevoir des jeux vidéo
uniquement pour le marché français ça
c'est déjà un point qui est très
important nous sommes donc au rang des
nations qui sont capables d'adresser le
monde avec nos références culturelles
européennes et françaises et donc
d'apporter aussi quelque chose de
différent en matière culturelle à celles
et ceux qui jouent on n'est pas
forcément dans le formatage à
l'américaine comme on pourrait
l'imaginer qui peut parfois avoir
tendance à se refléter dans les séries
dans certains films ou dans certains
même livres qui sont aujourd'hui
distribués dans notre pays l'avantage de
ce jeu vidéo c'est qu'il est capable
aussi de diffuser une vision et une
façon de percevoir la culture qui est
différente
nous avons 1300 entreprises aujourd'hui
en France qui conçoivent des jeux vidéo
directement ou indirectement parmi ces
1300 entreprises plus de la moitié sont
des créateurs de jeux vidéo ce sont des
sociétés dont la seule métier et de
réaliser des jeux vidéo avec des équipes
de production qui sont extrêmement
diverses des ingénieurs évidemment des
artistes mais aussi tout un ensemble de
métiers qui vont aller jusqu'à l'analyse
de données pour être capable d'interagir
avec leur communauté de joueurs on
l'évoquera sans doute tout à l'heure le
jeu la façon de jouer à évoluer et ce
sont des métiers qui sont venus dans nos
équipes aujourd'hui plus de 55 métiers
sont à l'oeuvre au quotidien dans
l'ensemble de ces entreprises et c'est
55 mais c'est 54 métiers évoluent
régulièrement si on prend la référence
de l'année 2018
l'avant-dernière référentiel des métiers
du jeu vidéo que nous avions réalisé
nous avions une quinzaine de métiers en
moins
parmi ces entreprises enfin dans ces
entreprises pardon nous avons
aujourd'hui à peu près 18000 emplois qui
sont des emplois à plus de 80% en
contrat à durée indéterminée ce sont des
emplois durables des emplois qualifiés
et des emplois qui sont établis en
France c'est très important car au cœur
de nos entreprises nous avons les
talents les talents ce sont celles et
ceux qui créent ce sont celles et ceux
qui développent les jeux vidéo et ce
sont celles et ceux qui sont recherchés
partout dans le monde et que nous
cherchons à faire venir sur notre
territoire pour réaliser les meilleures
productions qui seront vendues partout
sur la planète nous avons un enjeu
extrêmement important de faire venir ses
talents mais aussi de les garder dans
nos équipes car la compétition est
mondiale vous évoquez monsieur le
Président tout à l'heure le dispositif
du crédit d'impôt jeu vidéo si nous
n'avions pas le crédit d'impôt jeux
vidéo nous ne serions pas ici
aujourd'hui en train de vous parler de
cette industrie elle aurait probablement
quasiment disparu de notre territoire
cet outil a été déterminant pour faire
de la un des leaders de la création de
jeux vidéo il reste des choses à
accomplir on aura l'occasion d'en parler
mais on est déjà aujourd'hui un niveau
d'attractivité et de rayonnement
international qui sont extrêmement
importants
dans ce contexte là évidemment un
certain nombre de sujets doivent être
doivent être abordés évidemment la
question du développement de ces
entreprises et de leur capacité à créer
les meilleurs productions
internationales pourquoi est-ce qu'un
éditeur international viendrait au
hasard Microsoft choisir une société
bordelaise pour réaliser l'un des plus
grands jeux de simulation
au monde Flight Simulator tout
simplement parce que c'est la meilleure
équipe à ce moment là au monde pour
réaliser ce jeu et parce qu'elles
dispose des meilleurs talents donc nous
avons besoin évidemment d'avoir de très
bonnes formations pour pouvoir mettre
sur le marché des talents qui seront
ensuite employés dans nos équipes mais
nous avons aussi besoin de faire venir
des talents de partout dans le monde
parce que ces talents sont diverses ils
sont multiples et ils ont une façon
d'envisager aussi la création de jeux
vidéo qui est extrêmement différente
donc ce cet outil de crédit d'impôt jeu
vidéo permet aussi de faire de jouer ce
rôle d'attractivité et de faire venir
dans une compétition mondiale les
meilleurs productions dans nos équipes
un tout petit complément
force du marché de consommation français
le troisième en Europe
une pénétration la population française
absolument hallucinante et sans doute
pas au niveau de l'appréhension par les
pouvoirs publics de ce qu'il est dans la
société 60 je répète les chiffres 73%
des Français jouent 58% régulièrement
et quand on descend en âge évidemment
c'est c'est encore c'est des chiffres
encore plus impressionnants donc on
parle d'un média on parle d'un loisir
numérique qui aujourd'hui par exemple
pour la génération post 2007 et de très
loin le premier média de cette
génération c'est à dire loin devant y
compris la consommation de vidéos des
linéarisées type Netflix ou Amazon on
est dans le la déclaration même
spontanée dans tous les sondages qu'on
peut faire le jeu vidéo est 10 points
devant ce genre de de consommation de
bien culturel et pour autant on est sur
une génération qui plus elle consomme de
jeux vidéo et je le dis tout de suite
plus elle a des activités culturelles
par ailleurs monitor tous les chaque on
a une étude qui s'appelle l'essentiel du
jeu vidéo et en fait de manière assez
contre-intuitive à plus vous faites du
jeu vidéo plus vous intéressez aux
autres types de culture donc peut-être
qu'on y reviendra aussi dans la
discussion le jeu vidéo est une
ouverture sur les autres cultures et une
ouverture à d'autres mondes le monde de
l'animation le monde du cinéma etc de
plus en plus ça c'est un premier point
deuxième point très rapide on parle de
la concentration on y reviendra monsieur
le Président c'est vrai que c'est le
contexte économique dans lequel on est
des très grands groupes qui
s'intéressent aux jeux vidéo j'attire
votre attention sur sur une dimension
consolide pas assez dans ce cet enjeu de
concentration des entreprises du jeu
vidéo c'est que le jeu vidéo est devenu
un actif un actif culturel stratégique
c'est un aliment de la souveraineté
numérique européenne à tel point que le
Parlement européen il y a quelques jours
vient de produire un rapport le premier
rapport non législatif voté par la
commission culture du Parlement européen
qui fixe des perspectives extrêmement
ambitieuses pour l'Union européenne en
terme d'investissement dans le jeu vidéo
pourquoi parce qu'au cœur de ce rapport
il y a le jeu vidéo on peut pas perdre
la bataille du jeu parce que derrière
c'est pas seulement de la création
française ou européenne c'est tout un
imaginaire qu'on emporte comme dans le
cinéma et c'est aussi des ruptures
technologiques qu'il faut pas rater
quand on parle Métavers quand on part
réalité immersive c'est le jeu vidéo qui
les crée c'est pas d'autres industries
en partie aussi d'industrie mais en tout
cas l'innovation de rupture
technologique elle a toujours été depuis
50 ans à l'initiative du jeu vidéo on
pourra y revenir mais il y a des
exemples très concrets la réalité
immersive avec les casques oculus etc ça
date de très longtemps les premiers
metaves c'est 2003 2004 dans le jeu
vidéo donc quand on parle de ces
ruptures technologiques souvent et
Julien le disait
peut-être que nous c'est un défaut
d'explication qu'on a eu ces dernières
années mais je pense que le jeu vidéo
doit être regardé maintenant à l'aune
d'une industrie à la fois mature au sens
il concerne énormément de monde très
stable en termes de ce qu'elle génère
pour les ressources de l'État c'est plus
d'un milliard de TVA chaque année ce que
je rappelle régulièrement à Bercy
donc voilà et c'est une industrie je
finis là-dessus c'est de l'emploi il y a
une bataille pour l'emploi dans le jeu
vidéo avec une place à prendre pour le
jeu pour le jeu vidéo français qui peut
être accrue dans les 5 ans qui viennent
si on nous en donne la capacité et de
l'emploi non délocalisable partout sur
les territoires français 80% des
embauches l'année dernière ont été en
CDI dans le jeu vidéo donc voilà ça
c'est un topo global pour vous dire que
en tout cas nous ce qui nous réunit
c'est une vraie ambition aussi tournée
vers comment on fait croître le
territoire France la destination France
en termes de jeux vidéo et comme on
attire l'ego les grandes entreprises
mais aussi les petits studios
merci pour cette introduction qui déjà
nous dresse un panorama très complet de
votre secteur avec je n'en doute pas une
série de questionnements derrière on va
commencer par celle de Julien barjoton
qui est rapporteur des crédits
budgétaires pour le jeu vidéo entre
autres merci monsieur
le mérite en effet de démonter un
certain nombre d'idées reçues qui court
sur le jeu vidéo vous avez raison je
crois de rappeler d'abord et avant tout
l'importance de l'enjeu économique et
stratégique que représente le jeu vidéo
en France c'est un domaine de
l'excellence française qui est
moins connu peut-être que d'autres moins
rappelé mais c'est effectivement
extrêmement important de de le montrer
donc c'est la première série de
questions je vais essayer d'être bref
pour laisser la place à tout le monde
peut-être que ces questions d'ailleurs
seront reprises et complétées la
première question c'est comment faire
pour renforcer cette atout vous en avez
parlé mais notamment quels sont les
moyens pour développer cet écosystème
national notamment en termes d'école de
formation par exemple mais pas seulement
où effectivement de ce que vous
attendiez des pouvoirs publics pour
encore davantage renforcer votre votre
réussite économique ça c'est la première
série de questions la deuxième série de
questions évidemment c'est l'inquiétude
liée
concentration vous l'avez évoqué
notamment avec le rachat pour près de 70
milliards de dollars du studio betesa
par Microsoft il y a des problèmes liés
à cette concentration notamment
peut-être que vous pouvez nous en dire
davantage sur l'exclusivité
l'exclusivité de l'accès aux jeux le
plus populaire du monde qui est Call of
Duty et qui peut aussi poser un certain
nombre de de difficultés mais également
effectivement
sur le Président on a parlé donc je
n'insiste pas les lootbox ce type de
pratique qui se développe enfin
troisième série de questions là c'est
plutôt sur évidemment des sujets de
contrôle et des sujets d'évolution à la
fois en positif et en négatif quels sont
d'après vous les conséquences de
nouvelles pratiques comme la réalité
virtuelle qui est relancée par Sony avec
son son nouveau casque et en
contrepartie
quels sont vos appréciations sur des
pratiques qui sont considérées parfois
comme comme toxiques dans le monde du
jeu vidéo je ne fais pas tellement
référence à la violence de certains
titres etc même si vous pourrez nous en
dire un mot il y aura sans doute des
questions le système Peggy a été mis en
place pour informer les acheteurs y
a-t-il encore des évolutions à y
apporter et puis également le management
des salariés des frais parfois
l'acroniques sur les périodes de
bouclage qui sont longues et épuisantes
pour certains jeux et également des cas
de harcèlement de sexisme qui ont pu
être
révélés dans le monde du jeu vidéo quels
sont d'après vous les les modifications
les apports les évolutions que doivent
accepter les acteurs du secteur pour
transformer certaines pratiques donc
c'est à la fois une série de questions
qui vous demanderait comment on peut
améliorer votre place dans
l'industrie française et en même temps
comment renforcer et de quelle façon
renforcer un certain nombre de
régulation qui existe déjà mais qui
mériterait peut-être d'être complété
merci beaucoup
et répondre à cette première série de
questions il y a d'autres intervenants
qui vous interrogeront par la suite
merci Monsieur rapporteur peut-être sur
la première question qui est celle de la
la reconnaissance et comment renforcer
nos atouts vous avez bien identifié le
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
effectivement une industrie d'excellence
mais ce qui colle malheureusement à
notre peau c'est le déficit de
reconnaissance de cette excellence alors
le les joueurs et les joueuses ne s'y
sont pas trompés car les jeux vidéo
français sont réputés mondialement et
les succès commerciaux de nos
productions sont vraiment à la hauteur
de d'autres succès internationaux
savez-vous par exemple que l'éditeur de
jeux vidéo mobile le plus téléchargé au
monde est un éditeur de jeux vidéo
français qui est au Louvre qui s'appelle
voodo c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
mais ça révèle à quel point il y a
effectivement cette méconnaissance donc
je pense que le premier axe de de
développement c'est celui de la
considération la considération que l'on
porte à notre secteur
la considération et la reconnaissance à
la fois d'un point de vue je dirais
politique mais aussi médiatique il est
clair qu'aujourd'hui dans les médias le
jeu vidéo est souvent la cause de tous
les mots de notre société et je suis
d'ailleurs étonné que de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
au niveau des stations services on
viennent pas dire que la faute du jeu
vidéo mais je fais volontairement ce
trait d'humour pour vous montrer à quel
point parfois les choses peuvent être un
petit peu exagérées voire même ridicule
donc je pense que cette considération
elle est importante nous avons un
travail nous de lisibilité de
transparence et de d'accompagner
finalement celles et ceux qui ne
connaissent pas nos industries et nos
nos équipes pour vous montrer comment ce
conçoit le jeu vidéo et celles et ceux
qui sont dans nos équipes ce sont des
jeunes talents qui viennent d'écoles de
formation qui sont formés en France qui
sont effectivement des étudiants et des
étudiants qui vont suivre un parcours de
formation classique soit artistique soit
en management soit effectivement dans
les métiers technologiques et qui vont
ensuite arriver sur le marché du travail
enfin sur une formation supérieure
spécifiquement dans nos métiers car la
particularité de nos métiers c'est
d'être extrêmement segmenté dans les
compétences qui vont être requises pour
aboutir ensuite dans une équipe de
production donc on a un enjeu c'est
probablement le deuxième enjeu c'est
celui de la formation on a aujourd'hui
une cinquantaine de formations sur notre
territoire c'est formation pour la
plupart d'entre elles sont des
formations privées donc effectivement
difficilement accessible pour l'ensemble
des Françaises et des Français qui
souhaiteraient rentrer dans notre
industrie donc nous avons un enjeu à
rendre ces formations plus diverses plus
inclusive plus accessible et donc de
travailler aussi sur un développement de
la formation publique
nous entreprenons en ce moment avec avec
le sel de travailler auprès des
universités françaises pour essayer de
voir dans quelle mesure certaines
d'entre elles pourraient rajouter dans
leur cursus de formation
des unités de valeur sur les métiers les
compétences qui sont requises dans dans
notre industrie donc je pense que cet
axe de la formation il est très
important également à travailler et nous
nous y employons et nous aurons besoin
effectivement du concours des ministères
compétences sur le sujet pour y parvenir
et puis le dernier peut-être le dernier
point je veux pas être trop long sur
cette première question le dernier point
c'est celui de l'investissement
et elle rejoint la dernière votre
dernière question sur on va dire les
phénomènes de de d'agrégation et de
renforcement aujourd'hui des entreprises
par des capitaux étrangers produire un
jeu vidéo aujourd'hui pour les plus
grosses productions internationales
c'est plusieurs dizaines voire centaines
de millions d'euros cela dépasse
largement le budget d'une grosse
production hollywoodienne si en matière
de cinéma pour ce faire l'ensemble des
investissements sont réalisés avant même
que le jeu sorte
ce qui veut dire que vous devez avoir la
capacité à investir la totalité de votre
budget avant même d'avoir l'espérance du
moindre centime de gain cet
investissement
il permet d'employer évidemment des
salariés parfois plusieurs milliers sur
une production sur des durées
relativement longues parfois plusieurs
années son compte aujourd'hui entre 5 à
7 ans pour faire aboutir sur le marché
une très grosse production
internationale nous avons donc un enjeu
de d'irriguer nos entreprises avec des
capitaux qui permettent de financer
cette production donc ces capitaux soit
effectivement ils viennent d'autres
entreprises du secteur c'est le rôle des
éditeurs c'est le rôle des distributeurs
qui vont venir financer la production
c'est ce qui existait historiquement
dans notre industrie mais aujourd'hui on
a aussi de nombreux acteurs
périphériques qui vont venir
s'intéresser effectivement à notre
secteur d'activité car comme le rappeler
à Nicolas Vignol c'est un secteur qui
aujourd'hui est au centre de l'ensemble
de la consommation culturelle qui peut
exister de la part des personnes qui
vont jouer aux jeux vidéos donc donc on
a cet enjeu de réussir à capter des
investissements qui sont de bons
investissements pour nous permettre non
seulement garder notre capacité créative
et notre indépendance créative ça c'est
absolument indispensable garder nos
talents en France et qu'on continue à
pouvoir les employer durablement parce
que on sait quel est leur valeur et puis
également être capable de produire ses
meilleurs productions aujourd'hui on
peut constater que des efforts ont été
faits les investissements de la BPI le
fond qui a été monté avec liftick il y a
quelques années et qui a produit ses
effets le crédit d'impôt jeu vidéo
évidemment qui est un élément
déterminant mais
certains investisseurs privés ou
industriels s'intéressent aux jeux vidéo
mais on a besoin aujourd'hui d'avoir la
capacité à avoir des montants
d'investissement encore plus important
aujourd'hui seul les investisseurs
étrangers sont capables de mettre
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
dans les entreprises du jeu vidéo donc
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
comment est-ce qu'on peut réagir de
notre côté en France avec des
investissements qui sont des
investissements venant de nos
industriels français ou d'investisseurs
dans ces métiers pour venir irriguer
finalement la production de jeux vidéo
en France voilà pour répondre rapidement
à cette à cette première question
pour répondre au sénateurs
de manière assez concise finalement si
on avait quatre demandes à formuler pour
faire de la France leader en Europe du
jeu vidéo à 5 ans on aura on aurait
quatre quatre
leviers sur lesquels s'activer et
peut-être avec le concours du Parlement
un on a développé en France on a on a su
quand même le faire développer nos
startups avec le programme French tech
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir pour le jeu
vidéo à quelque chose d'au moins aussi
ambitieux puisqu'on sait que la
croissance de cette industrie dans le
monde est à deux chiffres que des pays
sont en train massivement d'investir sur
ce secteur et pas à l'autre bout du
monde parfois l'Allemagne est en train à
investir 100 millions d'euros dans un
plan dédié il y a deux ans
tout le monde est en train d'accélérer
puisqu'il a bien compris que c'était à
la fois une forte demande de
consommation domestique mais aussi
mondiale et que en Europe on a des
atouts formidables pourquoi ne pas faire
une stratégie un petit peu à légale de
la French Tech pour nous donner on est
inséré dans la french tech mais
insuffisamment aujourd'hui pourquoi ne
pas nous donner les leviers dont
bénéficie aussi cet écosystème et
finalement les chiffres sont assez
comparables quand on regarde le chiffre
d'affaires de 5 milliards 6
premier point donc un développement tech
économique appréhender le jeu vidéo
comme un enjeu tech et économique pas
seulement comme je le dis devant la
commission culture évidemment on est une
industrie créative et culturelle mais on
est aussi une on a une dimension tech et
stratégique de ce point de vue là j'y
reviens pas donc peut-être mieux nous
insérer là-dedans
faire de la France le pays le plus
attractif c'est pérenniser donner de la
stabilité j'y reviens pas je viens au
milieu l'a dit le CIGV
c'est pas une niche fiscale je suis un
peu provocateur c'est pas une niche
fiscale c'est un levier pour des
productions françaises la capacité à
produire du jeu vidéo en France et avec
une vision européenne et française qu'on
exporte dans le monde entier donc le
crédit d'impôt jeux vidéo et nous on
appelle de nos vœux monsieur le
Président l'objectivation que vous
appelez aussi de vos vœux nous on
appelle depuis longtemps un rapport qui
permet de d'établir que ce crédit
d'impôt après a permis de passer à 1300
entreprises en France a permis de passer
de 3000 emplois en 2010 après de 20000
aujourd'hui voilà nous on veut cet
objectif mais on attend de
l'administration ou du Parlement qu'il
conduit ce travail on sera à ses côtés
il y a pas de souci on est assez
confiant là dessus mais le crédit
d'impôt est un levier d'emploi et de
création de richesse
ensuite le 3 c'est le plan France 2030
on mise beaucoup sur ce plan on a besoin
voilà on s'est investi dedans le SNJV
c'est un très gros travail pour que les
studios et y ait accès mais vraiment
ouvrir grand le plan France 2030 aux
jeux vidéo pour toutes les raisons que
j'ai évoquées avant
et initialement juste une petite insiste
quand on dit manque de considération le
plan France 2030 et maintenant c'est
plus ou moins rétabli mais quand on l'a
lancé pas un mot pour le jeu vidéo pas
un mot pour le jeu vidéo
bon on lance pour le cinéma on entend
bien on lance pour toutes les industries
créatives pas un mot pour le jeu vidéo
dans le monde entier c'est l'industrie
culturel numéro 1 en France et le bien
culturel le plus consolé par les
français sauf quand il y a une BD
d'Astérix qui sort petit clin d'oeil
mais voilà pas un mot pour le jeu vidéo
donc c'est ça ce manque de considération
c'est aussi ça qu'on lance un plan pour
toutes les ICC parlons du jeu vidéo
aussi et enfin trois et quatrièmement
la formation j'y reviens pas à ce que ça
a été très bien développé mais nous on
est très très à vos côtés et aux côtés
du gouvernement qui est très sensible
pour développer des formations publiques
accessibles des 3ème cycles pour former
au métier du game design level designer
il y a des nouveaux métiers sans cesse
dans cette industrie il faut former plus
en France pour garder nos talents voilà
c'est les quatre leviers finalement
assez classique mais qui nous
permettrait vraiment en 5 ans de
connaître un vrai sort
merci je vais vous donner la parole
successivement donc Céline Boulley
Sperone dossier Annick billon Michel
Savin David Assouline j'aurais mon
Hugonnet Marie Pierre Monnier et Sonia
de la pauvreté
merci monsieur le Président et merci
beaucoup pour l'organisation de cette
table ronde pour un effectivement cette
première industrie culturelle en France
qui est si méconnue et moi j'aurais aimé
savoir comment vous pouviez faire pour
vous faire mieux connaître alors
évidemment l'organisation de cette table
ronde va aider je n'en doute pas et dans
les Territoires chacun pourra porter la
parole du jeu vidéo en France j'avais
plusieurs questions dont deux auxquelles
vous avez répondu la première concernait
la formation vous avez dit qu'il y avait
une cinquantaine de formations sur le
territoire parce que je déplorer moi
avant de vous entendre le fait qu'il n'y
ait qu'une école je crois de formation
qui était à Angoulême mais donc vous
m'avez rassuré sur ce point la deuxième
question concernait les perspectives de
croissance donc j'ai bien compris votre
volonté de devenir leader en Europe à 5
ans mais j'aurais aimé que vous
développiez un petit peu plus ce qui
serait selon vous des perspectives de
croissance et notamment dans le secteur
de la production avec une production qui
serait féminisée enfin etc si vous
pouviez développer un peu plus et deux
questions peut-être un peu plus précise
la première sur ce qu'on appelle le
système du Free to Play et notamment les
premium dans ces jeux gratuits aux
améliorations payantes est-ce qu'elles
ne pose pas une petite difficulté à la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui dans la mesure où
elle créerait une espèce d'addiction une
espèce d'addiction financière qui serait
peut-être dommageable et ça ça serait à
mettre au débit de du secteur du jeu
vidéo peut-être et deuxièmement j'aurais
trois quatrièmement pardon j'aurais aimé
que vous développiez la relation entre
jeux vidéo et consommation culturelle ne
serait-ce que pour rassurer un certain
nombre de parents qui pourraient penser
que le jeu vidéo loin d'être la première
industrie culturelle pourrait favoriser
chez les jeunes un phénomène d'addiction
qui irait à l'encontre justement de
cette ouverture aux autres cultures je
vous remercie on va prendre toutes les
questions si vous voulez bien
donc ensuite Thomas dessus merci
monsieur le Président et merci pour
cette présentation et beaucoup de
questions ont été posées sur les leviers
pour développer cette industrie
si importante moi j'aurais quand même
vous avez parlé d'une industrie mature
qui est à la fois la créative et
industrielle c'est une industrie qui
fait rêver beaucoup de jeunes qui
veulent se lancer aussi dans le
développement c'est l'industrie passion
mais on a vu il y a quelques années
quelques enquêtes journalistiques sur le
les coulisses un peu de cette industrie
culturelle et qui ont montré un décor un
peu moins mature que vous le présentez
notamment dans la dans la période où
juste avant la sortie du jeu ce qu'on
appelle le crunch ou là les heures
supplémentaires ne se comptent plus et
les salariés sont pressurisés en 2018 il
y a un salarié de l'industrie qui avait
une formule certainement caricaturale et
lapidaire mais qui disait que pour
bosser dans le jeu vidéo il faut être
trentenaire en bonne santé et
célibataire et dès qu'on avance un peu
en âge et avec une vie familiale ça
devient plus compliqué alors c'est une
enquête qui date de 4 ans peut-être que
les pratiques ont évolué peut-être qu'il
y a eu des chars ou des mesures qui ont
été prises j'aimerais bien vous entendre
là-dessus et puis ce qu'on a appris il y
a l'année dernière dans une enquête de
Libé c'était que dans les écoles de
formation cette culture était encore
présente même si elle l'était contredite
officiellement dans la façon dont ils
envisageaient les projets de fin
d'études ou les ou les ou les projets en
général il y avait encore cette culture
de des semaines de 80 heures pour
développer un projet etc parce que ça
faisait partie de ce qui était parce
qu'il pouvait être valorisé donc de
savoir si aussi dans la formation on
pouvait pas peut-être combattre ou même
limité un peu cette culture de la
pression sur les différents développeurs
et puis ça a été évoqué par mon collègue
barjoton mais il y a aussi eu des
problématiques mais comme dans toutes
les secteurs industries ou même
organisation des des révélations de sur
les violences sexistes et sexuelles dans
dans cette industrie là je veux savoir
s'il y a eu des mesures qui avaient été
prises et notamment parce que parfois
c'était aussi vous l'avez dit il faut
garder les talents il faut garder des
personnalités parfois très fortes dans
les dans les studios et parfois c'est
c'est en voulant garder et en les des
gens qu'on a évincé au mis sous cloche
certaines problématiques de violences
sexistes et sexuelles dans cette
industrie donc je voulais savoir si
aussi là dessus ça avait évolué je vous
remercie Annick billon merci monsieur le
Président merci madame messieurs pour
cette exposé et ses premières réponses
cette activité de jeux vidéo qui pour ma
part est assez inconnue puisque j'ai
jamais joué aux jeux vidéos en réalité
donc
je l'avoue humblement je voudrais
plusieurs questions mais je pense que je
ne suis pas la seule autour de la table
donc plusieurs questions sur les
périodes de confinement tout d'abord
sur les périodes de confinement tout
d'abord
quels ont été les conséquences en termes
de consommation et en termes de demandes
par rapport à ces périodes de
confinement puisque j'imagine que la
demande a été peut-être plus importante
et votre activité c'est-elle développée
à ce moment-là sur la création je vais
rejoindre les questions de notre
collègue dessus à l'instant quelle
limite vous imposez-vous en termes de
création à la fois par rapport à des
violences sexuelles sexistes par rapport
à la violence en général et par rapport
à des stéréotypes qui pourraient être
véhiculées dans cette cette création
puisque avec des collègues je préside la
délégation aux droits des femmes et avec
notamment Alexandra qui est face à moi
nous avons rendu un rapport sur
l'industrie de la pornographie il y a
quelques jours donc certains nous
disaient on répond à la demande on fait
de la création en fonction de la demande
donc jusqu'où répondez-vous au niveau
des jeux vidéo à la demande et sur un
troisième volet pour des questions sur
euh l'idée peut-être un peu stéréotypé
qu'on pourrait avoir des de la
consommation de jeux vidéo et aussi de
la répartition homme-femme qui travaille
dans ce secteur pouvez-vous nous dire
est-ce que vous avez des statistiques
sur la consommation et sur le public
puisque c'est un secteur en pleine
expansion et comme souvent dans la
technologie les secteurs en pleine
d'exposition plus souvent on retrouve
des garçons au niveau de l'orientation
et des études de merci pour ces réponses
ça va
merci Président Madame et messieurs vous
nous avez donc présenté aujourd'hui la
situation de l'économie et de
l'industrie de du jeu vidéo vous avez
monsieur répondu à une première question
en
ciblant les quatre leviers qui seraient
nécessaires pour
poursuivre et encourager et développer
cette activité est-ce que comment
voyez-vous son évolution et est-ce que
des aménagements législatif et ou
réglementaires
doivent-ils être réalisés pour lever ces
leviers donc vous avez un peu évoqué
mais peut-être préciser les choses
deuxième question qui rebondit un peu ce
que vient de dire à Nick bilan c'est
faut-il à vos yeux encadrer ou pas et ou
réguler cette nouvelle activité sans
pour autant menacer sa viabilité et puis
je vous donne un troisième sujet qui a
fait déjà débat au Sénat il y a quelques
mois lors du débat sur l'examen de la
loi sport ou le Sénat adopté la mise en
place d'un contrôle d'honorabilité pour
les encadrants de eSport comme pour le
milieu sportif je voulais savoir comment
se déroule sa mise en place et quel est
votre avis sur ce dispositif
merci pour votre vos exposés
je pense que ce que vous nous dévoilez
sur quoi vous insistez c'est que d'abord
ce sont c'est une industrie culturelle
absolument majeure pour lactée et c'est
vrai que certains
n'ont pas
considérés ou apprécié cela
deuxième chose que
une grande partie de la jeunesse si ce
n'est sa quasi-totalité
consomme ces jeux
et
troisièmement que il y a
une réelle créativité culturelle
et une excellente française reconnue
dans le monde
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
quand même
aborder et la France parce que vous avez
dit la France n'en parle pas trop ou ne
bon oui et non parce que le crédit
d'impôt c'est une aide d'État et vous
avez dit que c'est nodal et ça a été
central dans le développement de cette
industrie et sans cela il y aurait pas
eu grand chose et le crédit d'impôt
c'est forcément l'État qui donne même si
on pense que c'est parce qu'elle ne
prend pas
mais sur le fond je pense qu'il y a des
problématiques qu'on a besoin de
discuter
derrière le jeu
ce sont les principales communautés ce
sont les principaux réseaux sociaux de
la jeunesse
et ça c'est très peu après
c'est à dire que quand on se met en
communauté on dialogue
et des messages passent et y compris
aujourd'hui les stratégies de
communication y compris politique pour
certains
sont avant tout accès pensé pour
pénétrer ces communautés là voire même
les créer et nous on croit que ça se
passe sur Twitter et tout enfin pour la
jeunesse pas du tout c'est d'abord dans
les communautés de jeux vidéo
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils l'ont apprécié pour
ce qui est de leur domaine mais bon
les services par exemple savent que il
faut énormément être présent là si on
veut pouvoir aussi surveiller un certain
nombre de choses en termes de crime ou
en termes de terrorisme
mais moi je suis pas dans cette sphère
je suis dans la sphère de ce qui circule
du point de vue des idées de l'idéologie
du formatage et quand il s'agit de jeûne
10 14 ans quand même ça nous intéresse
et donc toutes les problématiques que
nous abordons sur les réseaux sociaux
l'éducation
toutes l'éducation aux médias que l'on
doit promouvoir
là il y a quelque chose de fondamental à
moi alors c'est de la régulation c'est
du regard c'est de la formation je ne
suis pas pour uniquement voir ça comme
un truc ou faut chercher à les militaire
réprimer etc mais faut pas non plus
faire comme si ça n'existe pas
et puis je veux je veux juste vous poser
une question parce que là
il y a quelque chose de très important
c'est effectivement
le type de valeur qui peuvent être
véhiculés dans deux domaines essentiels
la considération des femmes la dignité
des femmes
et la violence ça va avec parce que la
culture violente est souvent assez
machiste
je suis étonné quand moi je
consomme à mon âge que quelques jeux de
cartes et je vois qu'il y a des pubs
et ces pubs c'est je me demande comment
ça peut même être autorisé plus d'une
demi-heure parce que des fois elle perd
une surprise mais ensuite c'est régulé
mais des pubs d'une violence d'une d'une
dépradation de l'image des femmes
incroyables incroyable je sais pas
comment on peut continuer à faire
il y aurait une telle image sur
n'importe quel média ou réseaux sociaux
il y aurait tout de suite une réaction
donc voilà je veux vous poser aussi les
questions et je suis vraiment quelqu'un
qui a plutôt aidé y compris les
législations à faire que ce cette
industrie soit considérée et j'en
apprécie absolument le côté créatif et
pionnier enfin pas pionnier mais la
France est forte et je veux qu'on la
soutienne mais attention
à ne pas voir tout ce qu'il y a à faire
dans un cadre où les parents ne sont pas
là où les professeurs ne sont pas là les
gosses de 10 à 14 ans sont livrés à
eux-mêmes dans ces réseaux et ici passe
des choses qu'il faut réguler
merci président merci messieurs dames de
remarque une question la première
remarque c'est dans cet environnement
anxiogène que nous vivons aujourd'hui il
est heureux de commencer la journée avec
des gens qui ont voilà de l'envie de
l'ambition et et qui monte une réussite
certaine de ce secteur merci pour cela
la deuxième remarque c'est vous parlez
Monsieur le Délégué Général de d'un
manque de considération
je voudrais relativiser cela parce qu'il
est certainement plus facile d'avoir un
article favorable dans les médias que
d'obtenir un crédit d'impôt de nos jours
nous en parlons ici en connaissance de
cause donc voilà mais ça dit au passage
d'ailleurs que quand il y a un petit peu
moins d'impôts sur les entreprises comme
par hasard
ça fonctionne je pense que ça doit nous
amener à réfléchir aussi sur d'autres
choses ma question elle est très simple
que pensez-vous du divorce de l'année
entre électronique arts et la FIFA
Fédération internationale de football
et est-ce que vous pensez que la FIFA
peut être ce que vous appeliez tout à
l'heure un acteur périphérique c'est à
dire au rendez-vous 2024 qui va gagner
dans le maximum jeu entre électronique
arts et la FIFA
question précise Marie-Pierre meunier
merci président bonjour
Tout d'abord je vais parler protection
des mineurs face au contenu non
approprié en dehors des outils mis en
place par la loi dans les stars du
système de classification Peggy qui se
fondent sur l'âge du joueur et des
mentions dans la signature ouh là là
signalétique des jeux d'éventuels
comportement à risque et figurant quels
sont les leviers mis en oeuvre par
l'industrie pour protéger les mineurs
des contenus inappropriés y compris dans
une logique de prévention
addiction l'OMS reconnaît depuis 2019
l'existence d'un trouble de jeux vidéo
pour les joueurs et joueuses dans la
pratique intensive se fait au détriment
de ses activités ou de leurs activités
quotidiennes quelle est votre
positionnement sur le sujet
considérez-vous que les studios intègres
suffisamment cette problématique dans la
création et surtout la promotion de
leurs produits et puis égalité femme
homme
une enquête d'un journal a publié en 21
a dit que les problématiques enfin c'est
pencher sur les problématiques de
violence sexistes et sexuelles culture
d'école misogynes harcèlement agression
au sein des écoles de jeux vidéo très
prégnantes qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que il y a je crois en 2020
seulement 22% des employés du secteur
qui étaient des femmes c'est une
progression plus que je crois qu'en 17
c'était 15 mais les deux sont peut-être
liés peut-être qu'il y a plus de fables
les jeux seront autres que ceux que l'on
que l'on peut voir les chiffres sont
vraiment têtus c'est quand même un écart
significatif
donc êtes-vous à titre des syndicats
partis prenantes d'initiative visant à
davantage de féminisation dans ce
secteur pouvez-vous nous partager des
exemples de bonnes pratiques sur le
sujet d'école spécialisé dans le domaine
du jeu vidéo ou d'entreprise du secteur
sia
merci beaucoup en fait on se pose tous à
peu près les mêmes questions donc ça
tourne toujours autour des mêmes sujets
donc il y a les aspects négatifs le
danger les comportements à risque
certaines images
dégradées ou violentes de qu'on dégradé
de la femme par exemple quand on évoque
dans ces dans ces jeux vidéo mais il y a
aussi le côté positif c'est que ça peut
on peut avoir finalement voir dans ces
jeux à rôle pédagogique ou un rôle
culturel et ce sont finalement de
formidables outils de transmission de
valeur
et d'éléments culturels et donc et
d'ailleurs preuve en est c'est qu'au
travers du Pass Culture le jeu peut être
accompagné et que donc on considère du
point de vue des instances publiques que
c'est la participe de l'éducation
artistique et culturelle auprès des
enfants et des jeunes et donc moi je
voulais poser une question c'est
est-ce que de votre point de vue à vous
il peut il peut être mis en oeuvre à un
vrai un vrai pack une vraie
programmation d'intention sur les les
quelques années à venir de
systématiquement quand une création a
lieu qu'on qu'on
y mette de la culture qu'on y mette des
valeurs et que ce regard là soit c'est
en fait c'est une charte c'est une
charte éthique mais au-delà c'est
vraiment construire le jeu vidéo de
l'avenir surtout quand on parle de
metaves ou on voit les dangers que
peuvent amener potentiellement les
metaves construire le jeu du mideo
d'avenir comme étant un des outils des
politiques publiques et de transmission
de valeur et notamment pour la France
des valeurs républicaines donc c'est un
vrai sujet parce que c'est pas tout à
fait le regard qu'on porte et donc le
corollaire de cette question est-ce
qu'il faut passer absolument par la
violence des images et les mots
provocateurs ou fort pour que ça marche
je pense que c'est nous et donc c'est
donc du coup c'est je pense qu'il faut
vraiment
une lettre d'attention et ma deuxième
question porte sur
les les
arts ludiques parce qu'on appelle les
arts ludiques en général c'est à dire la
bande dessinée le film d'animation ou le
jeu vidéo où il y a des métiers communs
notamment dans le domaine du dessin et
est-ce que dans votre organisation de
filière vous avez intégré cette
dimension là à cette filière puisqu'on
voit bien que dans ces métiers un
certain nombre passe de l'un à l'autre
de l'une à l'autre des activités et que
finalement le vivier français déborde
largement le cadre du Vivier du du jeu
vidéo
et donc en même en matière de filière de
formation je pense que c'est une
dimension peut-être qu'il faut jouer il
faut jouer collectif d'ailleurs ce qu'a
fait Angoulême quelque part il faut
jouer collectif parce que finalement
notre potentiel à nous c'est c'est cet
ensemble de professionnels et de métiers
dans lequel on excelle particulièrement
je vous remercie
Bernard Keller
merci juste une petite question
complémentaire puisque beaucoup de
choses ont été dites dans ce domaine qui
est un domaine d'excellence pour le pays
qui est aussi profitable je voulais
savoir si quels sont exactement les les
engagements qui sont pris et les moyens
qui sont mis à disposition pour lutter
bon on a vu l'addiction et aussi donc
les phénomènes d'obésité et et de
diabète qu'entraîne quand même cette
addiction aux jeux vidéo est-ce qu'il y
a des actions particulières des
engagements qui qui sont pris et de quel
ordre sont-ils
voilà je vais en ajouter une sur le plan
économique on voit bien que des grands
groupes avec des moyens financiers
extrêmement puissants je pense à Tencent
côté chinois mais aussi les les femmes
sont en train de d'investir de manière
forte dans le jeu du jeu vidéo pour les
raisons que vous nous avez bien expliqué
compte tenu de la croissance du secteur
vous avez évoqué
à la fois l'utilité mais aussi la
faiblesse de certains de nos outils pour
nous protéger par rapport à ces prises
de capitaux quels sont les discussions
que vous avez avec l'État sur ces sujets
là et ce qu'il y a des modèles de
protection qui sont envisageables
on va vous laisser répondre à toute
cette série de questions ça vous avez vu
que ça allait un peu dans différentes
directions mais ça traduit aussi
l'intérêt de notre commission pour votre
secteur je ne sais pas qui commence le
président j'entends dans ces séries de
questions beaucoup de préoccupations
aussi de et notamment de de
volonté de protéger la jeunesse je
partage totalement ces préoccupations
c'est je pense que c'est on est beaucoup
à être parents autour de la table et
c'est des choses effectivement qui qui
nous inquiètent donc je voudrais
rappeler que le secteur du jeu vidéo
effectivement de sa propre initiative à
instaurer le système Peggy depuis de
nombreuses années qui est un système en
fait qui décrit le niveau de violence ou
de de
les propos à caractère sexuel ou voilà à
l'intérieur d'un jeu qui permet donc de
savoir par une série de pictogrammes
quel sera le contenu du jeu et mais
ensuite c'est une recommandation d'âge
pour pouvoir jouer à ces jeux donc il y
a on peut jouer à partir de 3 ans 7 ans
12 ans de 16 ans 18 ans donc ça c'est un
système qui existe depuis longtemps nous
en tant que en tant que syndicat on a
énormément
promus ce système en fait des campagnes
chaque année en fait pour effectuer
effectivement informer les parents sur
l'existence de ces de ce système PEGI et
moi je te le dis souvent quand je suis
interrogue sur ce sujet là c'est vrai
que on s'intéresse à ce que nos enfants
écoutent on s'intéresse à ce qui est à
ce qu'ils disent je vais regarder une
jaquette je vais de livres mais on a on
fait ça un petit peu moins pour le jeu
vidéo et ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment dommage donc en fait je pense
qu'il s'agit pas seulement d'éduquer les
enfants mais il faut aussi beaucoup
beaucoup éduquer les parents et ça on en
a tout à fait conscience on est alors
les choses évoluent parce que les
parents de plus en plus sont joueurs et
sont bien informés mais néanmoins on a
encore une frange de la population qui
est non joueuse qui est qui est un peu
qui se sent un peu él de ces médias et
donc on continue ses campagnes de
communication chaque année voilà donc le
système Peggy est un premier pan de
cette protection des mineurs
on a par ailleurs ces dernières années
et énormément
communiqué sur le système de contrôle
parental qui je pense est vraiment la
clé c'est la clé pour pouvoir à la fois
instaurer des règles et les faire
respecter donc vous avez sur l'ensemble
des consoles vous avez sur les
téléphones portables vous avez des
systèmes de contrôle parentaux qui sont
extrêmement bien faits et qui vont
permettre de définir et d'encadrer en
fait le
pas seulement le temps de jeu mais
également ce à quoi on joue ce à quoi on
peut être exposé les interactions avec
la communauté les interactions avec des
personnes inconnues on va pouvoir fixer
des limites en termes de dépenses on va
pouvoir fixer effectivement enfin
interdire des jeux qui ne seraient pas
qui ne jugeraient une donc selon le
système Peggy
voilà donc les systèmes de contrôle
parentaux existent sur toutes les
consoles ils existent sur les téléphones
portables et nous on continue
effectivement de communiquer parce que
je pense que vraiment c'est la clé à
partir du moment où les parents s'en
sont emparés et pardon
non c'est
alors effectivement il faut savoir ils
sont ils vont être plus ou moins
accessibles et plus ou moins ergonomique
mais moi j'ai un système de contrôle
parental sur pour de pour la switch de
mes enfants je définis le nombre
d'heures qui peuvent jouer par jour
je définis la console s'arrête à partir
du moment ils ont dépassé le temps de
jeu voilà donc c'est c'est et je pense
qu'en fait il est important que les
d'avoir ce dialogue avec ces gens avec
les enfants avec la jeunesse et de
savoir refléter à l'intérieur des
consoles les règles qu'on a on a posé
avec ses enfants donc ça c'est je pense
que c'est essentiel et on vraiment on
fait d'énormes efforts pour pour
promouvoir les systèmes de contrôle
parentaux parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment la clé
tu veux compléter peut-être juste pour
finir sur ce chapitre là en fait nous on
considère à vos côtés aujourd'hui c'est
pas que les industriels ont fait le job
mais sur le hardware désolé d'utiliser
cette anglicisme mais sur les matériaux
sur les équipements le travail a été
fait c'est à dire que sur les trois
grosses consoles du marché mais aussi
j'entendais les jeux en ligne un jeu
comme fortnite produit par l'éditeur
épique qui concerne tous les gamins dans
la cour d'école vous avez une limitation
du temps de jeu possible en sein en 5
clics par ailleurs les contrôles
parentaux qu'on évoque notamment sur la
Nintendo switch ou sur la Playstation ou
sur Microsoft Xbox on parle d'une
configuration en moins de 10 clics pour
des parents qui veulent s'en donner la
peine j'ai moi-même deux enfants
il y a évidemment du contrôle parental à
la maison j'ai une application sur mon
téléphone qui est gratuite je peux
monitorer si il allume la console il y a
un temps de jeu journalier ou 0 certains
jours c'est 5 clics donc aujourd'hui
l'enjeu c'est d'avoir les pouvoirs
publics le Parlement à nos côtés c'est
un enjeu de parentalité numérique de de
résoudre la fracture en fait ça s'insère
dans le combat contre l'inclusion contre
l'exclusion numérique c'est à dire que
les parents qui se sont démunis on
entend parfaitement mais comment on peut
se faire l'Allier des pouvoirs publics
pour promouvoir ces systèmes nous on
fait des campagnes chaque année comme
l'a dit ma présence on a la Paris Games
Week chaque année qui est un énorme
salon où on a un énorme stand et
d'ailleurs vous y êtes tous invité on a
un énorme stand qui s'appelle la Paris
Games Week junior ou avec 50 animateurs
on reçoit les parents on apprend l'usage
du contrôle parental mais voilà on est
conscient en tout cas qu'il faut un
usage raisonné raisonnable des écrans
nous ne sommes pas du tout une industrie
qui milite pour que les enfants passent
c'est aux côtés d'autres loisirs le jeu
vidéo c'est aux côtés en partage avec
d'autres choses donc on est très engagé
sur ces sujets là parce que l'industrie
il faut que vous compreniez qu'en fait
on a évoqué et le sénateur à soulignent
l'évoquer on y reviendra mais différents
modèles économiques et différents
acteurs numériques les réseaux sociaux
ont leur modèle d'affaires ce n'est pas
le modèle d'affaires du jeu vidéo le
Free to Play ont un modèle d'affaires à
insérer dans la famille du jeu vidéo qui
est un peu différent de des jeux vidéo
dont on parle là mais tous ces modèles
d'affaires sont très différents et le
jeu vidéo tel qu'on le promeut on le
défend alors il a appelé à évoluer
évidemment il y a plein de nouvelles
nouveaux modèles il repose quand même
sur une la volonté de créer un
environnement sain et sur c'est un
objectif autant c'est pas
philanthropique c'est même pas que
éthique c'est un objectif aussi
commercial la famille les jeunes parents
de 35 45 ans sont un objectif aussi
commercial de notre industrie on va pas
s'en cacher et quand on veut convaincre
ces cibles là pour le dire de manière
très prosaïque on doit créer son
environnement sain et sur donc notre
intérêt même industriel contrairement
peut-être à d'autres industries c'est de
créer cet environnement jeu sain et
assez accueillant et au moment du conf
et j'en finirai par là beaucoup de
familles se sont rééquipés parce
qu'effectivement à la faveur du
confinement je sais plus quel sénatrice
évoquait ça il y a eu un pic de jeu
effectivement qu'on a constaté et
notamment parce que les 35-45 ans les
parents ont voulu reconnecter avec leurs
enfants et ce sont dit bah tiens jouant
ensemble remettons une console au milieu
du salon et c'était la première
génération de parents qui avait fait du
jeu vidéo quand ils avaient 18 20 ans
ils ont vu l'occasion de raccrocher avec
leurs enfants et donc voilà le contrôle
parental c'est décisif pour cette cible
là parce que s'ils allument la console
et qu'il y a pas cet outil là pour nous
c'est de toute façon passer à côté de la
de la question donc là dessus on est
plus enfin on est des alliés je veux
dire on n'a pas d'objectif caché là
dessus c'est juste une promotion par les
pouvoirs publics à nos côtés pour
vraiment les le faire savoir moi je rêve
que dans les tiers-lieux qui promouvent
l'inclusion numérique il y ait des
petits espaces on puisse expliquer via
les médiateurs numériques par exemple
comment on configure une console en 4-5
cl pour pas laisser les parents dans la
pampa par rapport à ça je voudrais aussi
je veux pas mettre en position défensive
absolument pas mais je pense qu'il y a
on a souvent tendance à accuser le jeu
vidéo de tous les mots comme l'a dit
Julien précédemment mais je pense qu'il
y a effectivement il faut surveiller la
consommation de jeux vidéo mais il y a
quand même une addiction aux écrans de
manière générale donc et on a un peu
tendance à penser que à partir du moment
passe trop de temps sur son téléphone
c'est de la faute des jeux vidéo mais il
va on s'inscrit quand même dans un
contexte où je pense qu'effectivement le
le l'addiction aux écrans doit être doit
être surveillée et mieux encadré et de
la même manière sur un téléphone on peut
on peut on peut mettre des contrôles
j'ai moi-même des contrôles pour
moi-même donc pour sur pour surveiller
que je ne je ne passe pas trop de temps
sur mon téléphone donc je pense qu'il
faut pas il faut faire attention aussi
aux amalgames et je voudrais juste
réagir à une chose que que vous avez
dites qui qui me touche quand vous dites
les les joueurs sont les les jeunes
joueurs sont laissés à eux-mêmes
et ça je pense que c'est je
c'est c'est faux en fait parce que les
communautés de joueurs je peux vous dire
que chez nous les éditeurs elles sont
extrêmement surveillées il y a il y a un
certain nombre de propos qui ne sont
absolument pas tolérés vous avez des
vous avez des gens en fait qui
surveillent les communications en jeu et
il y a des systèmes de signalement et on
fait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts pour que le pour que le les
relations les relations les relations
entre enfin à l'intérieur des jeux
soient bienveillante en l'occurrence en
revanche c'est vrai que les communautés
de joueurs ne nous appartiennent pas
elles existent aussi indépendamment de
nos jeux elles peuvent s'exprimer
ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux et
c'est là et c'est effectivement qu'on a
pu observer un certain nombre de dérives
mais tant qu'elles sont à l'intérieur
des jeux donc in game je peux vous dire
qu'elles sont extrêmement extrêmement
surveillées et qu'il y a il y a ce qu'on
appelle enfin il y a une tolérance zéro
avec avec des propos voilà toutes sortes
de propos
intolérables qu'on peut tenir dans la
vie de tous les jours
la surveillance
alors je
vais peut-être apporter un point sur ce
sujet on l'a dit je crois que c'est un
sujet qui nous touche évidemment tous
nous sommes des créateurs responsables
engagés et il n'est absolument pas
question d'imaginer une seule seconde
que notre rôle est de diffuser des
valeurs qui seraient contraires à leur
public à la morale voire même qui serait
répréhensible
pénalement
l'ensemble de nos créateurs et nos
créatrices qui sont dans nos studios
font un travail énorme de documentation
des travaux préparatoires
lorsqu'il s'agit par exemple de jeux
historiques pour s'assurer que
l'histoire n'est pas tronquée
lorsqu'elle est proposée aux joueurs et
aux joueuses et donc il y a un
engagement de la part de ses créateurs
et de ses créatrices sur l'ensemble du
spectre de la création qui est totale
certaines des créations que vous évoquez
et on va pas le nier on n'est pas là
pour être en mode défensif sont des
créations qui peuvent être produites
ailleurs par des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans notre
domaine pardonnez-moi de compétences
donc nous avons aussi à subir comme dans
l'ensemble des secteurs qu'il s'agit des
secteurs culturels ou industriels des
dérives on ne peut que les regretter on
peut essayer de lutter contre ces
dérives et nous la première réponse que
l'on a c'est de en favorisant le jeu
vidéo français nous favorisons
l'émergence des valeurs françaises et
européennes dans la création mondiale
aujourd'hui on peut regretter que dans
les séries par exemple ou dans le cinéma
nous soyons abreuvés de référentiels
américains et que nos référentiels
européens ou français soient très
timidement mis sur le devant de la scène
quand on a un succès et qu'il est
international on s'en réjouit en général
c'est quelque chose de très positif dans
le jeu vidéo nous avons de très nombreux
succès ces quotidiens quel que soit le
type de plateforme et quel que soit le
type et le de jeu donc je dois rappeler
ici quand même notre engagement profond
à faire de cette création française et
européenne une création internationale
je vais revenir
juste pour compléter parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a parlé on a parlé de
violence de mais je voudrais aussi
rappeler que oui oui mais que les jeux
vidéo vous il faut pas il faut pas être
occulter en fait par quelques noms ou
quelques il y a aussi dans la production
de jeux vidéo des jeux vidéo qui vont
vous parler qui vont vous faire rêver
qui vont parler d'amour qui vont parler
d'amitié qui vont parler d'homosexualité
qui vont parler de genre donc voilà il
faut il y a tout une production et
notamment sur la scène indépendante qui
va vraiment qui amène une richesse et
une diversité de sujets qui sont
extrêmement intéressants
je pense qu'il était important de le
rappeler et on sera même de vous fournir
une liste de jeux qui effectivement vous
évoquez sénateurs Assouline la poésie il
y a de très nombreux jeux qui sont
extrêmement politiques et des jeux qui
apportent voilà donc
bien sûr je voudrais juste on va vous
laisser répondre aussi aux autres
questions j'ai essayé de regrouper j'ai
essayé de regrouper très rapidement les
quelques sujets je vais commencer par
celui du confinement juste pour vous
donner une petite une petite
photographie et vous rappeler ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette période on a
constaté évidemment un hyper dynamisme
du secteur au niveau de la consommation
qui a eu des vertus aussi au niveau de
la population puisque le jeu vidéo a
permis de rapprocher les générations qui
n'a pas joué avec ses grands-parents ou
avec ses petits-enfants ou ses enfants à
des jeux vidéo en étant confiné chez soi
ça pouvait être des jeux vidéo très
classique mais voire même des parties de
jeux vidéo plus approfondies avec une
expérience de jeu un peu plus profonde
qui a permis aussi à toute une un
ensemble de générations de comprendre un
peu mieux ce qu'est cette cette
industrie culturelle je pense ça a eu
des vertus et ça a permis de nous
rapprocher néanmoins pendant cette
période il y a eu une hyper fragilité de
la production tout simplement parce que
selon les typologies d'acteurs nous nous
sommes retrouvés dans des situations où
nous avions des entreprises qui étaient
occupées à distribuer leur jeu sur le
marché et à répondre à une très forte
demande mais en même temps nous avions
des entreprises qui étaient en train de
produire des jeux vidéo avec des vues à
moyen et long terme et avec des éditeurs
ou des distributeurs internationaux qui
freinaient n'étant pas du tout certain
de l'avenir qui était offert à ce
secteur sur nos marchés donc on a eu un
effet on a eu un effet quand même une
parabole finalement avec un dynamisme du
secteur très fort mais une décroissance
ensuite au niveau de la production qui
s'est senti la nécessité de mettre en
télétravail l'ensemble de nos salariés
qui a été quand même une épreuve mais
aussi aujourd'hui avec le recul quelque
chose de une grande opportunité aussi
pour l'ensemble des salariés du secteur
qui peuvent bénéficier de conditions de
travail parfois amélioré avec une
souplesse aussi sur l'accès au bureau et
la flexibilité ou l'hybridation comme on
dit aujourd'hui de la façon que l'on a
de travailler donc ça a eu des vertus
aussi de transformer finalement la façon
que l'on avait de produire ces jeux
vidéo sans sans nier évidemment toutes
les contraintes parce que il est plus
facile de télétrailler lorsqu'on a une
maison et qu'on est dans un
environnement plutôt agréable avec
d'autres personnes que lorsqu'on est
reclus tout seul dans son appartement
voire même dans son petit studio ou sa
chambre donc on ne nie pas que
effectivement ça a pu avoir aussi des
effets catastrophiques et on a
accompagné pendant cette période avec
des cellules d'écoute l'ensemble des
salariés du secteur nous en tant que
syndicat professionnel mais aussi les
entreprises ont su réagir très
rapidement en mettant à disposition des
numéros des psychologues des
psychologues et des psychiatres et
évidemment à se mobiliser très fortement
pour faire en sorte que chacune et
chacun puisse vivre cette période avec
un semblant de sérénité
on a vous avez parlé
vous avez parlé de nombreuses enfin vous
avez souligné de nombreuses inquiétudes
qui sont les nôtres aussi comme le
disait Julie Chalmet tout à l'heure
sur le sujet de la mixité de la
diversité je voudrais rappeler ici
effectivement les chiffres qui ont été
cités 22 23% et nos chiffres 2023 enfin
2022 qui sont publiés en 2023 je
l'espère montreront une progression de
la féminisation dans nos équipes on a
encore beaucoup à faire vous avez raison
madame la sénatrice et nous y sommes
extrêmement sensible on a peut-être
réagi un peu tardivement néanmoins on a
réagi avec fermeté d'abord la première
des choses c'est je crois que les
entreprises ont été sensibles et
percutés de plein fouet par ce phénomène
générationnel qui était la production de
jeux vidéo il y a quelques années plutôt
des jeunes hommes effectivement puisque
c'était effectivement essentiellement
eux qui jouaient qui étaient des
pratiquants et une industrie passion qui
excluait finalement toute forme
d'intégration de gens qui ne n'étaient
pas qui n'était pas passionné eux-mêmes
je crois que tout ça c'est en train
d'être derrière nous voir derrière nous
dans pas mal de sociétés dans beaucoup
de sociétés en France donc il y a une
hypersensibilité et beaucoup de travaux
qui ont été faits notamment des
politiques de RSE qui ont été mis en
place dans de très nombreuses
entreprises et parfois même de petites
entreprises qui se donnent les moyens de
progresser très rapidement parce qu'en
progressant sur la mixité la diversité
l'inclusion on progresse sur l'image et
sur les créations que l'on produit on va
pas se leurrer ça passe évidemment par
là créer dans une équipe mixte et
diverses c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
que créer dans une équipe qui est unique
en termes de en termes de genre mais on
a un enjeu aussi sur la mixité sociale
on en parle assez peu le jeu vidéo c'est
aussi un des loisirs qui est pratiqué
par l'ensemble des couches sociales de
la population et d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'initiatives sont faites par des
associations de quartiers pour essayer
de réintégrer des jeunes en difficulté
avec le jeu vidéo on en parle pas
souvent mais j'ai changé il y a que il y
a quelques jours avec une personne qui a
monté une association en région
vernalpes qui vise à faire revenir les
jeunes qui vivent dans dans les cités
autour du jeu vidéo et leur apprendre un
métier finalement autour de cette
passion qu'ils ont à travers notre média
donc ça permet effectivement de mettre
ensuite sur le marché de l'emploi de
réenchanter finalement c'est ces jeunes
et pour nous c'est une aubaine parce que
là encore la diversité de nos publics en
matière de création sera évidemment très
bénéfique pour la qualité des
productions qu'on sera capable de mettre
sur le marché très rapidement quels sont
les autres initiatives qu'on a mis en
place on a travaillé très activement
avec l'association human ingame qui fait
un travail formidable et qui a été aussi
un des déclencheurs de cette
féminisation et de cette mixité dans nos
équipes donc énormément d'initiatives de
formation de webinar de sensibilisation
mise en place de rôle modèle de très
nombreuses femmes qui acceptent
aujourd'hui et qui ose parler de leur
métier s'exprimer dans les conférences
nous-mêmes en tant qu'organisateur de
conférences d'assurer la parité sur nos
panels de faire en sorte que les femmes
chefs d'entreprises soient valorisées
autant si ce n'est beaucoup plus que les
hommes dirigeants d'entreprises dans le
jeu vidéo et il y en a et elles sont
extrêmement douées talentueuses et elle
crée des jeux aujourd'hui qui sont parmi
les meilleurs au monde donc ça c'est un
autre élément qui a été mis en place
nous au niveau du SNV on a mis en place
une charte qui oblige l'ensemble de nos
adhérents à adhérer à un ensemble de
principes et d'actions concrètes à
mettre en place au sein de leurs équipes
après je vais être très honnête avec
vous nous sommes une petite équipe on
n'a pas un rôle de police auprès de nos
adhérents mais nous nous assurons quand
même que l'ensemble des éléments qui
figurent dans cette charte sont
respectés et je dois dire qu'à
aujourd'hui sur nos 250 adhérents nous
n'avons pas constaté pour le moment de
dérive et de comportements qui sont
contraires à cette à cette charte donc
ça je crois que c'est très important de
le signaler des formations qui ont été
mises en place par le CNC
qui aujourd'hui sont obligatoires pour
bénéficier de subsides publiques en
matière de création de jeux vidéo vous
ne pouvez pas bénéficier d'une
subvention si vous ne suivez pas la
formation qui a été mise en place pour
lutter contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles au travail en entreprise et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est aussi
extrêmement intéressant et important
puisque de je ne sais plus quel est le
nom mais je crois plus plusieurs
centaines de dirigeants et dirigeantes
ont suivi ces formations depuis leur
mise en place en 2020
dernier point peut-être et je laisserai
la parole à mes à mes collègues sur le
sujet des heures supplémentaires et de
ce que vous avez évoqué dans les qui a
été relaté dans les médias là encore
nous n'y ont pas qu'il y a pu avoir un
certain nombre de d'abus de problèmes et
de d'absence de prise en compte de
certains salariés dans leur bien-être au
travail je crois pouvoir dire
qu'aujourd'hui ces méthodes là sont
révolues pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la médiatisation a
été faite et a permis d'engager un très
grand nombre de réflexions et de travaux
profonds au sein des entreprises qui
pouvaient être sujettes à ce type de
pratique donc ça a évidemment eu des
vertus le deuxième c'est que la façon
que nous avons produire les jeux pour la
grande partie d'entre eux qui sont
aujourd'hui distribués sur le long terme
c'est-à-dire distribuer en jeu qui
continue c'est une méthode de production
qui ne fait plus se rencontrer
finalement le studio de production avec
le marché
il y a un traitement conforme à la loi
alors publique et à la morale
voilà sur ces sujets
qui un mot madame la Présidente et après
je redonne la parole à ma présidente
peut-être répondre plus précisément à
aux interrogations qui avaient été
soulevées
vous donnez un élément pour bien
comprendre il y a plus de 30 000 jeux
qui se jeux vidéo qui sortent donc on
parle d'un continent donc quand on
commence à s'intéresser aux jeux vidéo
c'est d'abord cette diversité qui qu'on
aurait dû presque spontanément vous
évoquez quand on connaît pas le jeu
vidéo on peut ne pas connaître cette
diversité de jeu mais les jeux sont
absolument sont un univers c'est à dire
qu'entre des jeux d'aventure qui
demandent 100 150 heures pour le finir
dans des décors graphiques absolument
spectaculaires des jeux qui demandent 5
à 7 ans de production
stylistiquement graphiquement hyper
léché d'ailleurs je rêverais de pouvoir
allumer des consoles devant vous et de
vous montrer ces dernières productions
peut-être à faire à reproduire dans un
autre cadre mais vous êtes
chaleureusement venu invité à la Paris
Games Week je le répète si vous voulez
voir ces jeux ces dernières productions
mais vous parlez on peut parler de ces
jeux là on peut parler de jeux très
cageoal c'est-à-dire très du quotidien
qui sont pratiquer parfois et il y a pas
de jugement de valeur de ma part parce
que c'est des mécaniques qui sont très
dures à créer pour rencontrer le succès
c'est paradoxalement des jeux très très
concurrentiels un secteur très
concurrentiel des jeux qui sont le temps
d'un transport pratiqué sur le téléphone
mobile par des personnes comme un
passe-temps et puis au milieu vous avez
aussi toute une gamme de jeux de plateau
qui sont reproduits de manière
énumériques des échecs etc tout ça tout
ça c'est le jeu vidéo donc effectivement
quand on peut nous rétorquer mais il y a
de la violence dans le jeu vidéo oui il
y a de la violence dans le jeu vidéo
comme dans le cinéma de Kubrick il y a
mais il y a de l'hyperviolence oui il y
a de l'hyper violence oui bah c'est une
création artistique il y a l'hyper
violence et parfois la violence prête à
débat prête à même à à des déchirements
dans les communautés de joueurs parce
que ça peut être de la violence purement
esthétique qui sert pas une narration et
donc la communauté de joueuse et de
joueurs va être la première à réagir
négativement sur ce jeu en disant
qu'elle est intérêt et puis parfois vous
avez des narrations très fortes où il y
a de la violence mais ça raconte quelque
chose donc nous on est mal à l'aise
parfois pour défendre l'industrie en
disant bah oui mais il y a de la
violence oui bah oui oui il y a de la
violence mais parlons où elle se situe
quel jeu comment etc et puis dans ce
spectre dans cette univers c'est pour ça
que c'est dur à apprendre et en très peu
de temps il y a des des jeux également
comme une vocation pédagogique dans le
sens où un Assassin's Creed qui
développe même un mode spécifique qui
s'appelle Discovery où vous pouvez vous
plonger dans l'univers du jeu sans faire
le jeu pour autant mais vous balader
dans le décor et visiter les pyramides
égyptiennes évidemment visiter la nef de
la cathédrale Notre-Dame etc ça c'est à
pousser c'est à valoriser donc voilà je
voulais juste peut-être juste vous
redire que c'est vrai que pour nous
c'est difficile à apprendre parce qu'en
fait ce continent là bah on le
représente dans toutes ces aspérités
dans toutes ces différences dans tous
ces voilà donc
continuons là-dessus mais ce qu'on
essaye de de faire céder avec vous
et génération de parlementaires après
génération de parlementaires on y arrive
petit à petit c'est de ne pas projeter
un regard trop vite trop caricatural sur
le jeu vidéo c'est de nous non non mais
c'est pas du tout le reproche que je
vous fais mais c'est c'est ce qu'on a
combattu dans les années à venir c'est
d'air de dire bah si on regarde le jeu
vidéo regardons le comme avec la même
exigence qu'on a pour d'autres
industries culturelles et créatives
voilà et ça c'est juste ce qu'on demande
ou alors on dit je n'y connais rien
d'accord mais donnons-nous le temps de
mieux le comprendre et de mieux
l'appréhender voilà ça c'est un propos
liminaire je réponds à la question du
président Lafont sur la concentration
les arrivées massive de capitaux etc je
pense que ce qui est important
un investisseur peut-être asiatique et
peut-être américain et pour autant
vouloir s'investir dans le long terme
dans le jeu vidéo et y compris en Europe
donc c'est vrai que d'un d'un rachat à
l'autre ou d'une montée en capital à
l'autre
il faut vraiment regarder ça à la
lumière de est-ce qu'on va réussir à
garder des actifs en France en Europe et
comment on peut avec vous faire une
prise de judo pour que comme à la
manière de la French tech je reviens sur
mon début de propos on peut être de plus
en plus attractif sur le territoire
français sachant que on a des raisons de
se réjouir mais qu'on pourrait
l'amplifier encore on a les talents
puisque derrière le soubassement c'est
qu'on a l'école créatif française et on
a l'école d'algorithmie et mathématiques
c'est ça le soubassement français des
startups et du jeu vidéo c'est les mêmes
l'algorithmie française et l'école de
mathématiques c'est ce qui fait des
c'est ce qui fait aussi le le fait qu'on
a des talents dans toutes les boîtes du
monde et qu'on peut les mobiliser aussi
sur le jeu vidéo l'école d'animation
française pareil les gobelins je sais
pas toutes les mais ça ça produit des
cerveaux pour le jeu vidéo donc c'est
vrai que si on crée le financement en
France le soubassement d'être public et
on n'est pas très gourmand on demande
d'être publique on demande juste à
pérenniser le crédit d'impôt jeu vidéo
qui représente une somme pour les
dominés publiques mais honnêtement qui
se compare les yeux dans les yeux
facilement avec d'autres crédits
d'impôts on parle de 50 millions 50 à 60
millions d'euros pour être très précis
avec vous voilà qui qui soutiennent un
millier un tissu d'un millier
d'entreprises donc voilà donc voilà donc
concentration du secteur arrivé massif
de capitaux mais dans ce dans cette
réalité du marché accélération des feux
en Europe et en France je vous invite
vraiment je vous le partagerai monsieur
le Président le rapport du de la
Commission du Parlement européen qui
vient juste de sortir qui a été produite
par la rapporteur et française une
député européenne Laurence pharynque qui
a fait un travail vraiment excellent sur
non pas parce que les confusions nous
vont mais parce qu'il est très complet
sur le jeu vidéo et l'esport et
l'ambition européenne qu'il faut allumer
la Commission européenne s'en est saisie
et le 9 10 novembre en plénière au
Parlement européen le rapport va être
adopté et je pense que c'est le signal
qu'en Europe on va on va accélérer sur
le jeu vidéo
une dernière question de Samantha
gasbown et peut-être pourriez-vous dire
un mot aussi sur le sur l'esport et
Céline ah oui alors l'esport on fait un
très gros travail sur l'honorabilité des
encadrants tout à fait ça nous on est
très proche de l'association francisport
le sel et membre de francisport qui la
grande association qui essaye de faire
avancer du sport en France l'esport
c'est quoi c'est le jeu dit autrement
c'est le jeu vidéo compétitif parfois on
pense que ce n'est que du jeu vidéo
virtuel type on prend du tennis où on
prend du foot et puis on le fait sur
écran c'est pas ça l'histoire c'est pas
ça les plus grandes licences du sport
paradoxalement c'est c'est pas c'est pas
ça ce sont des jeux vidéo qu'on pourrait
pas pratiquer dans la vraie vie comme
League of Legends par exemple ce serait
dur de le faire dans la vraie vie et qui
réunissent des millions de fans à
travers le monde autour de quoi autour
un peu la même mécanique de sport des
joueurs ou des joueuses qui ont un don
absolument exceptionnel sur sur ce jeu
et qu'on est prêt à payer pour venir
dans des stats voir jouer sur des écrans
géants avec une production un peu chaud
comme un spectacle
le développement de l'histoire à travers
tout le pays donc ouais ouais ça se
développe bien en France pour résumer et
on est un pays très dynamique d'isport
et le président de la République je
finirai par là à 10 à 15 jours 3
semaines qu'il allait conduire une
grande politique d'attractivité dans
lequel l'histoire faisait partie il veut
attirer les plus grands tournois du
monde en France et on aura en 2023 un
très l'un des plus grands tournois au
monde qui s'appelle Counter-Strike sur
un jeu qui s'appelle Counter-Strike qui
va réunir 15 20
000 personnes à l'accord Arena qui sera
retransmis dans le monde entier
Samantha que ce bonne dernière question
oui c'est plus sous une dimension
pédagogue là que je vous interroge je
voulais savoir dans quelle mesure vous
vous travaillez avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et comment d'abord
est-ce que vous êtes entouré de
pédagogue dans vos équipes vous parlez
tout à l'heure du temps d'écran donc moi
je viens du monde de l'éducation et et
on sait à quel point aujourd'hui on
laisse le champ plutôt libre aux
établissements scolaires de laisser les
élèves avec des outils numériques pas
franchement très cadré le sujet c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi l'autonomie de
l'établissement mais du coup je me pose
la question du temps d'écran et la
relation que vous avez avec le monde de
l'éducation et plus particulièrement
celui aussi de la pédagogie est-ce que
vous travaillez ensemble ou est-ce que
finalement vous ne faites que cohabiter
j'ai envie de dire une fois qu'on rentre
les jeux vidéo à la maison et qu'au fond
on ne se parle pas tant que ça je pense
je peux pas vous faire une réponse
unique en fait ça va vraiment dépendre
de quel type de jeu vous développer ou
est-ce que vous voulez développer moi
j'ai commencé ma carrière chez Cocktail
cocktail qui développait les jeux à dis
à dibou donc que vous peut-être que vous
connaissez qui était des jeux éducatifs
donc oui on y avait un dialogue avec des
pédagogues et enfin
le système éducatif parce que les jeux
avaient publication à être une vocation
éducative
ensuite nous en tant qu'industrie avec
nos relations avec avec le ministère de
l'Éducation je peux je peux pas je pense
qu'on a on a vraiment du mal à nous un
dialogue un dialogue avec eux je pense
qu'ils sont assez
réticents
engagé ce dialogue après on nous sommes
des industriels je peux ça peut se
comprendre donc c'est pas on peut pas
dire que on est on est des relations
très très proches
néanmoins après on constate que certains
certains après ça relève vraiment des
individualités un certain professeur
vont utiliser des jeux vidéo pour voilà
Nicolas mentionné précédemment un jus
d'Ubisoft Assassin's Creed qui se passe
ici sur un Egypte donc on est dans
lequel on peut effectivement on pouvait
découvrir toute la vie des Égyptiens il
y a de nombreux exemples comme ça c'est
vraiment mais mais aujourd'hui non on
peut pas je peux pas vous dire que le
qu'il y a une relation soutenue avec le
ministère de l'Éducation peut-être pour
compléter ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
vrai que c'est souvent des initiatives
individuelles de la part de certains
enseignants ou professeurs d'intégrer
finalement cette relation aux jeux vidéo
au sein de au sein de leur parcours de
d'enseignement c'est très dur de faire
rentrer le jeu vidéo à l'école et
dans les formations même supérieures
tout simplement parce que on est vu
comme des industriels et donc on serait
présupposés là pour venir prendre notre
part du notre part du gâteau ce qui est
évidemment pas notre notre intention
c'est plutôt justement de participer à
cette éducation aux écrans et même
globalement d'essayer de diffuser des
des comportements positifs de savoir
finalement éteindre une console ou un
jeu au bon moment aussi apprendre aux
parents aussi à gérer la pratique du jeu
vidéo de leurs enfants parce que il est
vrai quand on met un enfant devant un
dessin animé on a tendance à lui laisser
regarder le dessin animé jusqu'à la fin
et ensuite d'éteindre la télévision et
lui demander de venir faire ce qu'il a à
faire dans le jeu vidéo en général c'est
on éteint la console d'un coup d'un seul
on perd sa sauvegarde donc effectivement
ça crée du conflit les parents sont pas
forcément sensibles à ce que ça veut
dire et c'est normal bon voilà il y a
aussi les parents qui faut pouvoir
toucher et sensibiliser donc on a un
travail nous à faire avec à la fois
l'enseignement supérieur l'enseignement
l'éducation c'est pas évident on y
travaille mais on n'est pas toujours
reçu comme on souhaite donc c'est des
initiatives individuelles mais qui
portent quand même leurs fruits dans
certains établissements ça c'est il y a
des vertus
je voudrais juste terminer peu sur cette
question je pense moi je regrette en
fait quand il est pas plus de dialogue
je pense au jeu vidéo aujourd'hui c'est
un vecteur extrêmement important en fait
pour la jeunesse je pense que le tous
les les jeunes sont sont
tous les jeunes je fais quasiment tous
les jeunes jouent et je trouve que il y
a probablement des choses aussi à
inventer et nouer notamment pour les
amener vers vers les métiers du
numérique vers la programmation moi
c'est une de mes obsessions je pense que
le voilà c'est il y a certaines
associations qui apprennent la
programmation par le jeu vidéo en fait
on commence on commence à faire des
lignes de code on prend et on crée son
propre jeu vidéo et je pense que là il y
avait vraiment quelque chose qui se perd
parce que le pour le coup je pense que
la programmation devrait être une
matière à part entière dans le dans
l'enseignement dans l'enseignement
public à l'école dès le plus et dès le
plus jeune âge donc voilà je pense que
j'ai pas la solution mais c'est ça fait
partie de des choses auxquelles je pense
régulièrement il y avait une remarque
sur le Pass Culture
alors c'est le cas on a été parmi les
pionniers sur le Pass Culture à l'époque
de sa préfiguration un certain nombre de
concepteurs avaient effectivement
proposé leur jeu après on a des
problématiques de modèles économique qui
sont attachés à cela et de diffusion de
diffusion massive finalement des jeux à
travers le Pass Culture mais néanmoins
c'est une très bonne initiative à
laquelle on a souscrit dès le démarrage
du projet
je voulais juste parce que
madame la sénatrice vous avez soulevé
effectivement un point et vous vouliez
une réponse sur le modèle freemium juste
vous rappeler que en fait cette pratique
de qui consiste à proposer du contenu
additionnel en cours de jeu elle existe
depuis toujours dans les jeux vidéo et
pas simplement sur téléphone mobile
c'est une pratique sur les jeux console
qui existent depuis très longtemps on
apporte du contenu additionnel en cours
de route et un jeu que vous allez
acheter 50 à 70 euros va au final vous
coûter peut-être le double parce que si
vous avez une expérience de jeu que vous
souhaitez un bien entendu plus
approfondi avec plus d'interactions et
plus dans la durée vous allez devoir
effectivement dépenser
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que spécifiquement sur la
pratique mobile des descripteurs
indescripteurs de contenu est apparu
dans le système PEGI en 2019 si ma
mémoire est bonne mais je vérifierai qui
montre effectivement aux joueurs et
joueuses que il y a des achats dans les
applications et ce n'est pas valable
d'ailleurs que pour le jeu vidéo puisque
il y a beaucoup d'applications
aujourd'hui qui sont
des présupposé gratuite que vous
téléchargez qui en fait sont finalement
payantes et où d'ailleurs vous avez
beaucoup de mal à vous désinscrire dans
le jeu vidéo c'est pas le cas les choses
en général sont plutôt énoncées
clairement donc on essaye aussi
d'informer je pense que ça c'est très
important informé et responsabiliser les
joueurs et les joueuses je pense que ça
c'est un mot clé qu'on doit qu'on doit
avoir ensuite du point de vue de la
production on met en place des dépenses
des limites pardon de dépenses
c'est-à-dire qu'on est capable
d'informer les joueurs quand il y a
effectivement on détecte un abus on est
capable d'envoyer des messages voire de
signaler voire même de bloquer l'accès à
un compte donc ça c'est des choses qui
se sont faites qui continuent d'exister
quand il y a effectivement quelque chose
de d'inapproprié d'inadé voilà on ne
parie pas sur ce genre de sur ce genre
de choses
ensuite l'hypercajuall qui est
aujourd'hui un segment qui s'est
beaucoup développé ces dernières années
travail majoritairement maintenant sur
des modèles de revenus publicitaires
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est plus le joueur
ou la joueuse qui paye mais ce sont
finalement le fait de voir des
publicités alors on peut critiquer le la
vertu ou non de ce modèle là mais il a
au moins pour mérite de ne pas faire
porter sur le joueur la dépense qui
consiste en fait à lui proposer d'aller
plus loin et d'avoir une profondeur de
jeu et d'expérience un peu plus
importante donc ça je pense que c'est
important de le rappeler et dernier
point et j'en aurai terminé
on a quand même un phénomène de
l'abonnement dans le jeu vidéo
aujourd'hui qui se développe un peu à la
façon de ce qui existe dans le phénomène
dans les dans les séries notamment et de
plus en plus
d'opérateurs de plateformes proposent
des abonnements abonnement à un
catalogue auquel vous allez pouvoir
jouer de façon illimitée tant que vous
êtes abonné donc ça pose d'autres
questions mais néanmoins ce modèle là
étant en train de se développer
fortement c'est aussi une proposition
alternative qui est offerte aux joueurs
et aux joueuses qui n'ont pas forcément
envie d'être sur les modèles freemium
que vous évoquez
merci pour ces nombreuses toutes ces
réponses à nos nombreuses questions je
crois que c'était très utile de vous
entendre en tout cas c'est une audition
que
nous attendions et je vous remercie des
d'y avoir participé parce qu'il faut que
nous suivions davantage aussi ce secteur
à la fois pour les la dimension
économique que vous avez mentionnées
mais aussi le fait que c'est un vecteur
important de de d'informations et
communication à destination pas
uniquement des jeunes mais de l'ensemble
de la population donc c'était très utile
cette table ronde ce matin et Nicolas
qui a rien échappe précise qu'il y a un
jeu qui s'appelle Assassin's Creed Unity
qui se passe ici au Palais du Luxembourg
vous étiez voilà
c'est déjà gros Perrin sont déjà dessus
[Rires]
bien et on se retrouve tout à l'heure à
16h45 en salle Médicis pour l'audition
de Madame oudea cassera à tout à l'heure